Okay, so this talk tries to actually
borrow ideas from psychometrics, which
is the field of psychology that actually
models how can we measure human
intelligence and
other traits. And makes sense that we
can apply the same ideas to LLM. And I
think it's a very promising field to to
research and also to apply. Um
with this talk I will try to make that a
more common knowledge in the industry,
which is I think is very useful for
benchmark creators and also users of
LLMs that are trying to evaluate which
model is the good one for for them.
And also I will share all the
benchmarks, tools, and data set that I'm
going to show you here. So we can kick
off this kind of practices in the
industry.
So I'm going to start with the basics.
When we evaluate one model, we have one
number per model
with a benchmark, which is more or less
the accuracy, the number of times that
that model got a question right, okay?
But if you split that number into
different items, into different
questions, um if you think about that,
we have a strong assumption, which is
every item should weight the same into
this measure, okay? Which is a huge
assumption. For example, two items could
be correlated or for example, one item
could be pure noise because it's not
good or maybe one item is by far more
important than others for whatever
reason I don't care, but we are not
actually modeling that. And for that
we're going to apply modern
psychometrics that allows us to actually
model in a better way and estimate in a
better way everything here, okay? So
what I'm going to do exactly? I'm going
to order items and models by
difficulty and also intelligence here or
or ranking on the benchmark, okay? So
you can see this pattern and I'm going
to keep the entire vector, the entire
matrix. Okay, I'm not going to sum
anything up.
The thing here is with that we're going
to estimate two numbers. For each item,
I'm going to estimate B, which is the
difficulty level of that item. As you
can see the shape of the curve for each
item is going to be different and one of
the factors is going to be how difficult
is that. That curve is actually
describing how we map the intelligence
of the model against the probability of
getting that answer right. Okay, so very
difficult questions are going to be like
this because it's extremely difficult.
You you need a very high intelligence
level to get only 50% of the time that
that question right. Okay, and the other
way around we can see that. Okay, so for
each item we have that and for each
model we're going to estimate another
number, which is going to be theta.
Theta is going to be represented here by
this number. Okay. So
theta is on the same as scale as B. This
is a very good property.
And is actually distributed with a
normal distribution. Also helps to
understand what's is going on here
because our model with a
theta of zero means that this average on
this distribution. Okay. So for example,
let me show you one here one example,
one item.
This one.
No.
That one. Okay, so here this item for
work four, work four has a theta of oh
oh .1. Yeah, so that estimates a 67% of
probability of getting it right. And
actually we got it right with an item of
B minus .2.
Okay, so
that's the curve that we're going to
estimate for every item and also every
model is going to be
estimation of that theta, okay? So, also
we are going to have discrimination.
Discrimination is going to be how the
steeper that curve is. We prefer that
kind of curve because it's more
informative.
We don't like flat lines because that's
pure noise. It's not related with the
intelligence level. And we don't want
the inverse ones because that means that
that item is actually hurting models
that are very good, okay?
So, with that in mind
now we can estimate, for example, from
group four, if we pick the real answers,
we are going to put all together all the
item curves, and we are going to
estimate
the likelihood of the theta value that
maximize that pattern. And with that we
can estimate the value. And this
estimation is very good because actually
we can have a confidence interval here
with the distribution, which is
something that we get for free in IRT
modeling, which is this modeling that we
are we are applying here, okay?
So, we can have two cases here. We can
have two models with the same theta or
similar theta, but different scores, for
example, 95 answers and 116 answers. But
the other way around is more
interesting. For example, Claude here,
Opus 4.1 and Gemini 3 Pro, they have
actually the same score on the benchmark
here, but they have a hugely different
theta. They have one standard deviation.
And the reason for that is because we
pay attention to the actual answers that
every model has has
has actually in their data set, we can
actually estimate the theta with a
better prediction, okay? So, with that
in mind, we have a lot of applications.
So, this is super useful because we can
actually
audit our benchmarks.
And I'm starting this is cool, so if you
want to apply the same ideas to your
company or your benchmarks that could be
useful, okay? So, we are going to use
in this case the
parameters of each item to decide which
items are good for me or which items I
need to
go over again or maybe I need to remove
them.
So, we are going to use a, which is the
like the
slope parameter, the the information
parameter, and we are going to pay
attention to that because on the right
side here you have like uh standard
logistic curve here where
the
higher the theta, the higher the
probability of getting the answer right,
okay? Which makes sense.
Also, we have here very flat lines like
the ones that I showed you before.
We can keep those items if we need more
items, but those items are not going to
be very informative, okay? We are
actually uh wasting time on some of
them.
But also, what
my final words on the other side, we
have negative um
A's, which means that the item is
behaving in a weird way, okay? That is
quite common, and actually, you can use
a test and a statistical test to find
out which items are actually negative.
So, you can pay attention to them. It's
quite common that um a negative
A means that that item is mislabeled or
has some kind of error, okay? Because
good models are getting that item wrong,
okay?
So, for example, here you have two items
from a real data set.
In this case, it's uh
yeah.
It's we are asking a
a question, and the gold answer, the
answer that we have on data set is not
right. I didn't know that. I was
checking with the LLM.
And the same thing here, uh we have a
good item that has an older correct
answer that is this number one. So, for
that reason we have negative A's.
So, this is one of the most exciting
applications that you can use actually
here.
And there is one paper that is talking
about this application. It's called Tiny
Benchmarks. I highly recommend you that
paper.
But I'm going to explain how to apply
that and with this skill actually you
can use that for your own benchmarks.
Uh it's quite common for companies to
have private benchmarks about their task
or their
area of interest.
And they use those benchmarks to decide
which model
is worth it to implement on the company,
okay?
So,
do you need to apply the same benchmarks
multiple times to different models,
maybe to different harnesses, maybe to
different uh
fine-tunings of the same model.
And sometimes we don't need the entire
benchmark for that. Okay, so we are
going to use IRT modeling to reduce the
size of the
benchmark. So, let me show you how can
we do that, okay? I'm going to pick two
real benchmarks here. I estimated their
uh
A's and B's.
Um
and we can actually order them. We are
going to start with the most informative
item. And we can go with the next one
and the next one, okay? So, I'm going to
try to get a 99
correlation between the real estimation
of the model
and the estimation that I get with the
the small version of the benchmark,
okay? So, we will try to reach that
line, okay? Over time. Here time or here
the X axis means that how many items I'm
going to use
um
in this whole version. So, as you can
see as
if we we end up with all the items of
the benchmark, we get obviously the same
number that we got before, okay?
So,
Okay, so now things are going to get uh
more interesting, I think. Even if the
application are not so obvious
with the mathematical framework that we
have right now, we can actually get in
very interesting answers to different
questions that we can have. So,
I'm going to use the concept of
residuals or outliers to catch a few
patterns that makes no sense. And one of
them is going to be super useful for
benchmark creators because we can
actually detect if an item
was leaked uh intentionally or not. Um
to the internet. So, another model knows
about that question, so it's not valid
for my benchmark, which is a huge
problem. So,
as I was explaining before here in this
matrix, I can order by difficulty and by
intelligence. So, I can see this pattern
from green to red.
And if you pay attention to that, you
can see weird things. Like for example,
here Gemini 3 is getting this question
this uh yeah, this question is wrong,
but makes no sense because
based on beta value of Gemini 3 Pro,
we should be able to answer that by far.
We have 86
percent of yeah, 86%. And the other way
around, we can also have here
uh
deep seek yeah, deep seek here has a
very low probability of getting that
right, but even with that, uh
uh we got to uh
to green
questions here, okay? So, we can use
that
to calculate our residual error, to
calculate how unlikely is that
to see if we can extract a few patterns
from there, okay? And also, IRT allows
you to
do that item by item and also user by
user. In this case, user is model.
So, I can actually calculate which model
is the worst one in terms of fitting
into the parameters that they have. So,
for example here, 04 mini is the worst
one because you can see that there is
more inconsistencies.
Here, we have more green answers
among red parts, okay?
That's useful, for example, to detect if
a model is behaving correctly or is
unstable because you have a problem in
the I don't know, GPU platform that
you're using or whatever. So, this
parameter actually can catch errors on
inference.
Um but also it can helpful for us to
detect if a few items has been leaked on
the internet. For example, here, I can
have a suspicion that this item here
could be leaked on the internet, okay?
And
with that
we can go to the next technique.
So, connecting with the previous idea,
we can use adaptive testing, which means
that I'm going to pick the right items
for you on demand. So, for different
users, I can use different items, and
for different organizations, I can use
different items. So, I can have policies
like this item should not be exposed to
this specific organization, or this item
should not be exposed to
I don't know,
to this user or I cannot expose this
item more than 10 times per month. So,
you can have a policy of
to control how fast your models
your your benchmark are being trained
on, okay? So, let's say that we have two
organizations
that you
are kind of suspicious about and you
think one of them is actually leaking
the data on the internet, okay?
So, we are going to have here a private
private bank of items and we're going to
pick a few of them at random. We are
going to try to pick different levels of
difficulty because we need a good
common ground to share among all
organizations to estimate values on the
same scale, okay? So, this is really
important to pick.
And let's say that we have two
organizations A and B and for the
organization A, I'm going to pick this
anchor
set. And we're going to pick what we are
going to call fingerprint set for that
specific organization, which is going to
be a set of difficult questions because
I want to detect the outliers
that are only that are going to be a
specific or unique for that
organization, okay? Or at least we are
going to try to be
to reduce the overlapping with other
organization. And for the organization
B, we're going to pick another set of
difficult items
that are going to be different, okay?
So, if we suspect that organization A or
B is leaking the data,
we expect that over time
the new models are going to get better
for those items depending on the
organization that are leaking them,
okay? But they are going to get good at
those items in a weird way, in an
unexpected way, okay? So, we can detect
that with residual loss, with with the
person fit uh technique that I was
talking about
before, okay? So, here in this matrix
here, I have the receivables. As you can
see here, we have
R
and all of them you can see here, they
are not huge. They are below one
standard deviation, okay? So, actually
this data is is uh
is a synthetic data set, but I trained a
model with a few questions. I fine-tuned
a model with a few questions from a data
set and I tried to actually detect which
data set has been leaked. And actually
what happens is that I pick the five
items that I
uh provide to the organization A. I
train I fine-tuned a model with those
items. And as you can see here, I have a
huge average receivables over two
standard deviations compared with the
other ones, with the control ones, okay?
We need obviously
another set of uh
organizations and models that are not
being
um
trained on the benchmark to compare
with, okay? But with this technique, you
can actually detect if you have a leak
of information. You can use different
fingerprints to detect which is the
source of that leak, okay? So, I think
this is extremely useful for benchmark
grade.
So, in psychometrics, it's really
important to know if your test is uh
fair in terms of uh how we evaluate
different groups.
So, uh let me show you an example.
Sometimes we have an item that is using
a term that is only understandable in
one country, okay? So, if you use that
item, you're actually not
um
measuring intelligence. You're actually
measuring which country this person is
from, okay? So, that's our problem
because we are mixing two different
traits that you don't want to mix.
Uh we can use the same kind of
techniques for elements, but not for the
sake of fairness, but for the sake of
understanding how models behave with
different items.
So, I'm going to use split the data set
into Anthropic and OpenAI.
And for each item, I'm going to plot two
different curves, one for one group and
one for the other one. Okay? So, as you
can see here, for the same level of
intelligence,
I have a huge gap between those two
curves. That should not happen, but if
that happens,
maybe I can find an explanation
somewhere. And if that difference is
systematic among different items, I can
find those items. This is interesting
because actually, if you use those IDs,
I'm not going to show the items because
I don't want to leak them. But if you go
to the database and you go to for you
look for those items, you are going to
see some interesting patterns. You are
going to see that OpenAI gets right a
few
items that share
uh a few properties between them. Okay?
So,
this is useful to study in which parts
your models are good.
Um and we can understand actually how
they are related between them. Okay?
Okay. So, um
now that we understand what the proceed
was are, uh they kind of behave less uh
like a fingerprint. Okay? We can we can
analyze models and we can detect, for
example, if a model is distilled from
another model or we can detect if a
model is trained with the same base
model than others because [snorts] we
are assuming that if you make the same
mistakes or the same kind of mistakes or
you have the same pattern of residuals,
we should be able to see some kind of
connection between models. So, what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to pick
all the residuals for each model and I'm
going to correlate those vectors. I'm
going to plot here a correlation matrix,
okay?
And also I'm going to here to plot that
projection, a very simple one, okay? So,
before going into anything else, you can
pay attention to the colors of the labs
and you can observe that we have a few
clusters. They are not extremely clear,
but you can actually look at here. You
can You can see here that the same
family of models have the same kind of
errors. Also, we have here DeepSee
DeepSee I think. Yeah.
This is DeepSee.
R1 R1 and R1, okay? So, we can observe
some kind of patterns here, okay? But
the most interesting thing for me is if
we pay attention to the correlations,
we can see a few things that are useful.
For example, we can detect if model is
based on the same checkpoint, which is
in this case DeepSee R1.
Two different distillations, they share
a lot of their
answers, a correlation of point
0.3,
actually.
And also we can detect, and this is
extremely important for myself and for
some clients, we can detect if a model
has been
distilled from another one. And this
evidence actually is stronger than
actually evidence from the answers.
Sometimes we try to trick the model with
prompts to know if that model has been
trained with
choices from another one. But actually,
if you pay attention to the signals, you
have a strong guard signal to detect
that.
Also, you have another example.
We have the same model but with
different effort levels. We have also
very strong correlation here, almost the
same model.
And also, you can see different
generation of the same model that have
been
Probably they share out of the of the
weights, okay?
So, again, another example of
successors here.
From Gemini 3 Pro to Gemini 2.5 Pro,
okay? So, this analysis is a huge
opportunity to understand what how the
market is behaving, how models are
related between each other. And also, I
think this is an opportunity to improve
robust systems.
To pick the right model for each task.
So, for example, we know we can know if
a few models are good in different kind
of task or they are anti-correlated, so
you should pick between them.
Honestly, I think this is only the
beginning. There are many other useful
applications of psychometrics in LLM
evaluations. I'm extremely excited about
a few of them. For example,
you can merge benchmarks to improve the
quality of all of them together.
You can use secondary signals like
tokens and latency. And also, there is a
cute topic of multi-dimensionality that
actually I'm researching right now.
I can observe that LLMs and humans are
extremely similar in their their
structure of intelligence. In any case,
if you want to explore any of those
things or you are curious about them,
please let me know.
Thank you so much for your time. I hope
that this is going to be helpful for
you. I want to share all the materials,
all the skills, and all the tools so you
can use that in your day-to-day work.